the opening scene features a timid and
humble woman named Georgia bird who
lives a life of frugality by depriving
herself of various luxuries including
love she works as a salesperson in a
cookware section of Kragen's department
store in New Orleans and is also a
member of the Baptist choir Georgia has
a passion for cooking and enjoys
watching cooking shows on television
often attempting to recreate the recipes
in her spare time however she refrains
from tasting the food she prepares as
she fears gaining weight instead she
captures photographs of her creations
and stores them in a scrapbook labeled
possibilities which brings her a sense
of contentment she may starve to death
but at least her insta is fire at her
workplace Georgia is constantly harassed
by her boss who seems to be dissatisfied
with her performance regardless of her
efforts one day her boss reprimands her
forgiving leftover food to Beggars
stating that this store is not a
charitable organization despite her
explanation that the store has always
had a tradition of helping those was in
need her boss hands her a copy of the
store's magazine and orders her to read
it however as soon as he departs Georgia
tosses the magazine into the trash
frustrated with the constant pressure
she endures at work the good thing about
the workplace is that Georgia Harbors a
secret infatuation towards a handsome
co-worker named Sean Williams she has
even featured him in her treasured
scrapbook as her ideal husband and
hopefully not food that she will one day
eat little does she know that Sean also
has similar feelings for her luckily the
Christmas season brings a chance
encounter where Sean follows the scent
of George's cooking and asks her if he
could have a taste after taking a bite
he compliments her culinary skills and
reminisces about the aroma of his
mother's kitchen this brings the two
clothes and they delve deeper into their
conversation but suddenly Georgia
becomes clumsy and drops the spoons
feeling self-conscious in Sean's
presence she apologizes and attempts to
pick up the utensils but accidentally
hits her head on a kitchen cabinet door
causing her to lose Consciousness in the
next scene Sean rushes Georgia to the
Health Center in their store where she
undergoes a CT scan unfortunately the
results are devastating it reveals that
Georgia is actually suffering from
terminal brain tumors caused by a rare
neurological disorder known as
lampington's disease the doctor informs
her that she only has three weeks left
to live dude I thought this was a comedy
Georgia is left in a State of Shock and
disbelief unable to come to terms with
Her diagnosis however in addition to her
medical prognosis she also faces the
daunting reality of having to cover her
medical expenses herself as her HMO plan
is insufficient to cover the high costs
of her operation as night Falls Georgia
sits at her dining table in a very bad
mood her appetite is totally gone and
she doesn't want to talk to anyone she
reaches for her cherished scrapbook of
possibilities flipping through its pages
and feeling the weight of her
unfulfilled dreams tears fall as she
contemplates the unfairness of it all
but soon a sense of clarity settles over
her and she realizes that she must
accept the reality of her situation
Georgia decides that she will not spend
her last moments in a hospital
undergoing treatments that will only
prolong her life by a few months instead
she decides to embrace the time she has
left and live the life she has always
dreamed of with a newfound determination
she resolves to spend her remaining days
doing everything she has ever wanted to
do I'm gonna eat
Ian Williams the next day Georgia
marches into her boss's office
determined to quit her job but the
latter is dismissive and refuses to
engage with her causing her frustration
to boil over in a fit of rage Georgia
grabs her shoe and smashes his phone she
then stands up to him and declares her
resignation despite her boss's efforts
to keep her on board by offering a race
Georgia remains Resolute and walks out
of the store ready to pursue her
passions following this she heads to the
bank to liquidate all of her assets
determined to live the luxurious life
she has always wanted with the clock
ticking she knows that she must make
every moment count then Georgia embarks
on her dream vacation at the luxurious
Grand Hotel pup in the Czech Republic
spa city of carlavivari during her
flight she encounters some inconvenience
with the man seated in front of her and
expresses her displeasure to a flight
attendant unable to resolve the
situation alone the flight attendant
seeks the help of a senior colleague who
offers Georgia a first-class seat as a
solution she instantly switches to her
first class as money isn't the issue for
her anymore there Georgia gets served
with an exotic wine and a big turkey
upon Landing Georgia waits for a taxi to
take her to the hotel but she is
impatient so she decides to rent a
helicopter instead as she arrives at the
hotel people start to wonder who this
important looking figure is she walks
into the reception to check into her
room but learns that it isn't ready yet
she arrived earlier than expected
Georgia requests any available room and
is offered the presidential suite that
costs four thousand dollars a night
regardless Georgia doesn't mind the
price and pays for it which makes her
attract more attention to herself my
word Mariam that woman is positively
flush later while waiting to be checked
into her room Georgia spots the owner of
the store she used to work at he is
Kragen an eccentric millionaire who
always spends his Christmas at the same
Hotel she learns from a hotel staff
member that Kragen is with his mistress
and that they will soon be joined by a
Louisiana power broker Senator dillings
and Congressman Stewart following her
arrival at the luxurious Grand Hotel pup
George's determination to live the rest
of her life to the fullest is apparent
as she indulges in a designer's wardrobe
and takes full advantage of the hotel's
spa services her sense of adventure
leads her to attempt snowboarding and
base jumping off of a dam all while Rel
relishing in The Delectable meals
prepared by the famous chef diddler
Didier despite all this Georgia remains
kind-hearted and honest which is
appreciated by the hotel staff with the
exception of the unfriendly guest
services manager Miss Gunther meanwhile
back in George's Hometown Sean grows
increasing concerned about her absence
and seeks answers from the doctor the
news of her terminal illness comes as a
shock to him alarmed Sean goes to her
house to check on her but doesn't find
her there instead George's nephew
approaches him and shows him George's
scrapbook revealing about her trip to
Europe as well as her feelings for him
with this Revelation Sean becomes more
determined to get her back so he makes
the decision to fly to Europe on the
other hand Kragen and the other
influential people are having their
dinner when Stewart can't help it notice
George's Beauty and charm intrigued they
decide to approach her and learn more
about her they join her at her table and
strike up a conversation Senator
dillings and Congressman Stewart are
particularly interested in her plans for
the weekend and agree to join her in
whatever she has in mind as they chat
Kragen becomes increasingly suspicious
of George's motives and wonders if she
has any intention of harming his
business however the others are drawn to
her Carefree spirit and open Nature they
wish to know what it feels like to have
a soul after taking a leisurely walk
Georgia returns to to the hotel and
encounters Craig and the rest of the
group who are enjoying a game of chance
they invite her to join them which she
immediately accepts Georgia even bets a
considerable sum of money on the same
number three times in a row despite
being unfamiliar with the rules of the
game surprisingly her lucky number 17
proves to be auspicious and she wins all
three bats but instead of feeling elated
she feels angry with God for showing her
luck when she only has a short time left
to live disappointed she decides to stop
playing and cash out all of her chips
with the help of Kragen's assistant she
converts her chips to cash and gets
astounded to learn that she has won a
whopping amount of one hundred thousand
dollars as time passes Kragen's initial
curiosity about Georgia begins to morph
into something darker jealousy worried
that she may be a representative from a
rival company Craigen becomes
increasingly paranoid that she has been
sent to steal his business partners away
from him this feeling of unease is
exacerbated by the close relationships
that Georgia is forging with powerful
figures like Stuart and Dylan's in an
attempt to uncover any potential dirt on
her Craig and bribes the cunning Miss
Gunther to snoop through her belongings
and gather information about her
background in the next scene Miss
Gunther searches George's hotel suite
and comes across a letter that Georgia
has written containing instructions for
the disposal of her remains after her
death moved by the letter and touched by
George's Sunny optimism and
self-confidence Miss Gunther finds
herself in a moral dilemma on the one
hand she has been paid by Kragen to find
Shady evidence and on the other hand she
wants Georgia to live out the last days
of her life in the happiest way possible
after a bit of thinking she ultimately
decides to confess to Georgia that she
has read the letter urging her to return
home and spend her final days with those
she loves taking Miss Gunther's advice
to Heart Georgia sets off for the
airport the following day eager to
return home however her plans are
quickly derailed when she discovers that
an avalanche has blocked the road
leaving her stranded in the Czech
Republic little did Georgia know Sean is
stuck in in a taxi on the other side of
the snowdrift unable to reach her after
a while Georgia returns to the hotel
while Sean abandons the taxi and trudges
through the snow on foot to find her
that night Chef diddler invites Georgia
to assist him in the hotel's Kitchen in
preparing a luxurious New Year's Eve
Feast during the festivities diddler
publicly acknowledges George's
contributions and thanks her however
Kragen enraged by the attention Georgia
is receiving seeks to embarrass her in
front of his companions by revealing
that she is just a sales woman in one of
his stores despite his efforts though
Georgia remains composed and unbothered
stating that she never shared anything
about herself and that people simply
made assumptions without knowing the
facts she reveals to the group that her
illness was the reason behind her
extravagance spending and her decision
to live life to the fullest however
Georgia doesn't want to make anyone feel
uncomfortable so she promptly leaves the
table after wishing everyone a happy New
Year after the commotion ends Kragen's
Associates are appalled by his
insensitivity and choose to support
Georgia leaving him alone at the table
following suit Craig and secretary also
decides to leave him behind you're a
freaking dick Craig dejected and
embarrassed Kragen retreats to an upper
floor of the hotel and sits on a Ledge
contemplating whether to end it all when
Georgia finds out about this she
immediately rushes to the scene to talk
him out of it hoping to change his
outlook on life Georgia reminds him that
true happiness comes from being kind and
less driven by greed back in Louisiana
George's doctor discovers that the CT
scan that had originally diagnosed
Georgia with lampington's disease was
actually incorrect due to a faulty
scanner in reality she is not terminally
ill at all the doctor is eager to share
the good news with Georgia and rushes to
find her upon arriving at her residence
he meets with her nephew and they send a
fax to the pup hotel to inform Georgia
of the mistake in the meantime Sean
successfully overcomes the snow draft
and reaches the hotel where Georgia is
perched on the ledge chatting with
craigan it appears that she is finally
convinced him to to reconsider his plan
although the situation is a bit awkward
Sean musters up the courage and
confesses his true feelings for her
Georgia happily accepts his proposal and
they Embark their relationship with a
passionate kiss downstairs in the lobby
Miss Gunther discovers a facts from
George's doctor and rushes to deliver
the good news to her when the latter
finally discovers the truth she screams
with happiness along with everyone else
now with a new outlook on life and
determined to pursue their dreams
Georgia and Sean return to Louisiana as
a loving couple together they open a
restaurant named George's joint the
restaurant's success attracts the
attention of famous chef emeria Lagos
and Chef diddler who make an appearance
and celebrate George's Newfound success
the final scene shows that Georgia has
changed her book of possibilities into
the book of realities her friends from
the hotel including Craig and secretary
and Miss Gunther have all moved on to
live happier and more fulfilling lives
Kragen himself who had earlier tried to
commit the unthinkable has instead
joined a spiritual retreat to find
Solace the movie ends on a happy note as
Georgia and Sean eventually tie the knot
promising to always be there for one
another